one of the big topics of discussion in
the crypto Community is proof of work
versus proof of stake now obviously the
Bitcoin Community they are Ardent
supporters and Defenders of proof of
work they claim that it is necessary and
it is the entire point of Bitcoin but
there are many other proponents outside
of Bitcoin in the larger crypto
ecosystem that claim we need to move to
proof of stake that it's better it's
more energy efficient and it brings
advantages that are not provided by
proof of work Jack mullers the founder
and CEO of strike a Bitcoin company that
I've invested in was recently at the
Bloomberg crypto conference and he was
asked about this exact debate proof of
work or proof of stake what do you think
Jack here's Jack's great response the
fact that if a lot of people want to
create Bitcoin it becomes more difficult
is why the thing works your relationship
with Bitcoin is not a liability your
relationship with Bitcoin is not a proxy
to some Foundation some team some
corporate structure some development
decision in fact founder of Bitcoin he
she or they might be [ __ ] dead
and it's working really well Matt
that's what sailor means when it's a
property there's no liability
relationship like stable coins there's a
liability there it doesn't mean stable
coins are bad
Matt I own a security it's called strike
stock
Securities aren't bad building liability
relationships like Tesla stocks not bad
but there's a liability there with Elon
and the company and their roadmap and
their cash balance right and so like
proof of stake your relationship with
that asset it's a liability a stable
coin your relationship with that's a
liability in theory what you want is a
monetary asset where there are no
liability relationships that's the whole
point of the thing that's what proof of
work solved that it was a it was like an
amazing Innovation proof of stake if
proof of work is like we finally got an
airplane to fly
so it's a quote of a friend of mine
proof of stake is like we know how to
make it cheaper faster and less carbon
efficient just by not flying it's like
well like that's not like a competitor
that's just a totally different product
so sorry I got a little animated now
Jack absolutely Nails it here which is
that a blockchain the entire point is to
drive security that there is no
liability a blockchain which was
invented to create Bitcoin actually
gives the individual self-sovereignty it
allows them to now have digital property
rights you do not need to rely on a
trusted third party any one individual
or any group of people this is a Brand
New Concept being brought to the digital
world there are hundreds of millions of
people around the world that have
adopted Bitcoin specifically because
they want that ability to participate in
a peer-to-peer decentralized system of
which proof of work insurers will remain
proof of stake it sounds great it's
highly Innovative there are plenty of
projects that are going to use it but it
is something different it is separate it
has its own advantages but it does not
accomplish the goal of proof of work
blockchains ultimately Bitcoin is trying
to become digital sound money I'd argue
that it already has and if more and more
people continue to use it that
programmatic monetary policy will
protect their purchasing power proof of
work is necessary proof of work is an
advantage and proof of work will
continue to be adopted globally proof of
stake is distinct separate and different
good luck to the folks who are building
on it they're trying to do something
different that's okay Bitcoin is Bitcoin
uses proof of work and that's never
gonna change